This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学习法》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人背负着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，去听学。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听艰难的方式。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的大脑都炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着剧集的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些困难，你会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的。听听2%。这就是在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听的TWO.%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. The new listeners, old listeners, whatever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. A question I get a lot on the podcast is how to date as someone who is anxiously attached. How to date as someone who has a lot of anxiety and kind of worry to do with romantic attachment, to do with intimacy, to do with connection. And I think that it is a lot more common in this day and age than we perhaps acknowledge. So I thought today, what a great opportunity to break down what attachment theory is,
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信我，宝贝，闺蜜们》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这个播客专门探讨我们二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。无论你是新听众、老听众，还是来自世界哪里的朋友。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，我们一起剖析二十岁的心理学。我在播客中经常收到的一个问题是，作为一个焦虑型依恋的人应该如何约会。作为一个有很多焦虑以及对浪漫依恋、对亲密关系、对连接有所担忧的人，应该如何约会。我认为在当今时代，这比我们可能意识到的要普遍得多。所以我想今天，这是一个绝佳的机会来剖析什么是依恋理论，
some of the misconceptions about it, and then focus in on those of us who are dating with an anxious attachment style, what that looks like in a relationship, and how we can kind of move past these tendencies. Of course, we had to bring on a guest, Hayes Gibson, who knows so much more about this than I do. She is incredible. Welcome to the show. I'm so excited.
关于它的一些误解，然后重点关注我们这些带着焦虑型依恋风格约会的人，这在关系中是什么样子的，以及我们如何能够超越这些倾向。当然，我们不得不请来了一位嘉宾，海斯·吉布森，她对这个领域的了解比我多得多。她太棒了。欢迎来到节目。我太兴奋了。
So for those of you who don't know, Taise has this incredible YouTube channel, which I'm going to refer to first where, and a lot of other things as well, but the YouTube channel was really how I kind of like began to consume your wisdom and your work. where you break down a lot to do with attachment theory and dating, not just in our 20s, but at all ages. But can you give the listeners kind of a little bit of a, a little bit of a blurb of who you are?
所以对于那些不知道的人，泰丝有一个令人难以置信的YouTube频道，我首先要提到这个频道，还有很多其他东西，但YouTube频道确实是我开始吸收你的智慧和作品的方式。你在那里剖析了很多关于依恋理论和约会的内容，不仅是在我们二十岁的时候，而是在各个年龄段。但你能给听众简单介绍一下你是谁吗？
Yes. So basically I run a business called The Personal Development School. We put all sorts of content on YouTube. I am like obsessed with attachment style of people. I just love human behavior. I love talking about dating and relationships. It's been a huge passion of mine. And I actually ran a client-based practice for about 10 years.
是的。所以基本上我经营着一家名为个人发展学校的企业。我们在YouTube上发布各种各样的内容。我简直对人们的依恋风格着迷。我就是喜欢人类行为。我喜欢谈论约会和关系。这一直是我的巨大热情。实际上，我经营了一家面向客户的诊所大约10年。
and just had a very long wait list of like two years or so. And so it was like, okay, that's not really the best solution. So how do I kind of reach more people in a way that makes sense? So we eventually put a whole bunch of different online courses together, have the personal development school. I've written a couple books and basically put out free content on YouTube all the time. Like almost every day, lots of information. And there's a big focus specifically around dating, attachment theory,
并且积累了非常长的等待名单，大约两 years 左右。所以就觉得，好吧，这其实不是最好的解决方案。那么我该如何以一种合理的方式接触到更多的人呢？所以我们最终把一大堆不同的在线课程组合在一起，创办了个人发展学校。我写了几本书，基本上一直在YouTube上发布免费内容。几乎每天都有，有很多信息。这里有一个很大的重点，特别围绕着约会、依恋理论，
the subconscious mind, and like really how to change our attachment style. Because I think attachment style is this thing that maybe you're thinking about it, but it really is kind of in the backdrop of a lot of our decisions and a lot of our actions, particularly when it comes to love, but any kind of relationship. So making people more consciously aware of it is so valuable because I think attachment theory is one of those like phenomena where once you understand it, so much about your life begins to make sense. so much about your life. It's like suddenly crystal clear. Are you able to like briefly break down what attachment theory is for people who might not have an understanding? Absolutely. So first of all, I think what everybody needs to know is that every single person has what we call an attachment style. So attachment theory is basically the work of John Bowlby originally done and he talked about how our relationship in terms of how we learn love and connection. In other words,
潜意识，以及真正如何改变我们的依恋风格。因为我认为依恋风格可能是你在思考的事情，但它确实处于我们许多决定和许多行动的背景中，特别是当涉及到爱，但任何类型的关系都是如此。因此，让人们对它有更多的意识是非常有价值的，因为我认为依恋理论是那种一旦你理解了它，你生活中的很多事情就开始变得有意义的现象之一。你生活中的很多事情。就像突然变得水晶般清晰。你能够为那些可能不太了解的人简要剖析什么是依恋理论吗？当然。首先，我认为每个人都需要知道的是，每个人都有我们所说的依恋风格。所以依恋理论基本上是约翰·鲍比最初的工作，他谈到了我们关于如何学习爱和连接的关系。换句话说，
how we learn to attach to our caregivers in childhood, basically become the set of rules that we think for our adult lives in terms of what love is supposed to look like. So we sort of take these rules, these ideas about how we're supposed to attach to others, what connection is supposed to look like. And we essentially start living our adult romantic relationships by those rules. But I found when I first went back into attachment theory, there were a couple things missing.
我们如何在童年时期学会依恋我们的照顾者，基本上成为我们成年后关于爱应该是什么样子的规则集。所以我们有点接受这些规则，这些关于我们应该如何依恋他人，连接应该是什么样子的想法。并且我们基本上开始按照这些规则过我们的成年浪漫关系。但我发现在我最初重新审视依恋理论时，有几个东西缺失了。
Number one was this idea of, okay, well, what if we don't have a healthy set of rules, right? What if we have an insecure attachment style? there really wasn't much information on how we can change to become securely attached. And the second thing is, you know, there's not a ton of information about how each of the different attachments I'll interact with one another. And that's like really mind blowing. Like when you said a moment ago that if we have, you know, the awareness of what each of the attachment cells are, suddenly everything kind of makes sense. You know, before we understand that every single person has an attachment style and this is a subconscious set of rules we have for love, often what we don't realize
第一点是这个想法，好吧，如果我们没有一套健康的规则怎么办，对吧？如果我们有不安全的依恋风格怎么办？真的没有太多关于我们如何改变以变得安全依恋的信息。第二点是，你知道，没有大量的信息说明不同的依恋风格是如何相互作用的。这真是太震撼了。就像你刚才说的，如果我们对每种依恋风格都有了意识，突然间一切都变得有意义了。你知道，在我们理解每个人都有依恋风格之前，这是我们对爱的潜意识规则集，通常我们没有意识到
is happening is it's almost like we're sitting down. And if you can imagine as an analogy, we sit down and we try to play a board game with somebody. But they have a different set of rules for how the game is supposed to be played. Like you have the rules for Scrabble. I have the rules for monopoly. Like it's going to be chaos. And so when we finally can realize, oh, we just have different rule books. And oh, now I know what your rule book is. I can read it. Oh, you know my rule book. We can find a way to work things out and to create something new and something amazing. But without that, we usually purse lines everything so much and we take on all this confusion. So because of that, there's four major attachment styles that everybody really needs to know and understand.
发生的事情是，这几乎就像我们坐下来。如果你能想象一个类比，我们坐下来，试着和某人玩棋盘游戏。但他们对游戏应该怎么玩有不同的规则。就像你有拼字游戏的规则。我有大富翁的规则。这将会是一团糟。所以当我们终于意识到，哦，我们只是有不同的规则手册。而且哦，现在我知道你的规则手册是什么了。我可以读它。哦，你知道我的规则手册。我们可以找到一种方法来解决问题，创造一些新的和了不起的东西。但如果没有这个，我们通常会把一切都个人化，并承担所有这些困惑。正因为如此，每个人都真正需要知道和理解四种主要的依恋风格。
And every single person has one of these four styles. So the first style is statistically the style that does the best in relationships, has the easiest time. They are called the secure attachment style. Securely attached people essentially get a lot of really healthy parenting in childhood. So they get a few key really crucial components. Number one is they learn that if they cry or express emotion, their parent uses something called approach-oriented behavior. Basically goes towards them, wants to understand what's going on, tries to meet their needs.
每个人都有这四种风格中的一种。所以第一种风格在统计上是关系中表现最好的风格，经历最轻松。它们被称为安全依恋风格。安全依恋的人基本上在童年时期得到了很多非常健康的养育。所以他们得到了几个关键的真正至关重要的组成部分。第一点是他们了解到，如果他们哭泣或表达情绪，他们的父母会使用一种叫做趋近导向的行为。基本上走向他们，想要了解发生了什么，试着满足他们的需求。
Number two, because they try to meet their needs, they feel, the child feels safe, relying on other people and expressing their feelings and expressing their needs to others. And they learn to trust, number three. And number four, because of all of this, they feel this deeper sense of self-worth. Like, I'm just loved for who I am. My needs are worthy of being that by others just because. You're not because I earned it, not because I'm good enough or did something for it, but just because I exist.
第二，因为他们试图满足他们的需求，他们觉得，孩子觉得依赖别人以及向别人表达他们的感受和表达他们的需求是安全的。他们学会了信任，第三。第四，由于这一切，他们感到了更深层次的自我价值感。就像，我因为我是谁而被爱。我的需求值得被别人满足，仅仅因为。不是因为我赢得了它，不是因为我足够好或者为此做了什么，而仅仅因为我存在。
And so securely attached children grow up to be adults with a really healthy rulebook. They think, hey, I can meet other people's needs. I can listen to their emotions. I can express my own. I can express my own needs. Healthy boundaries are okay. I'm worthy of love for who I am. I don't have to earn it all the time.
所以安全依恋的孩子长大后会成为具有非常健康规则手册的成年人。他们认为，嘿，我可以满足别人的需求。我可以倾听他们的情绪。我可以表达我自己的情感。我可以表达我自己的需求。健康的界限是可以的。我因为我是谁而值得被爱。我不必一直去赢得它。
And so securely attached individuals statistically, according to the last, like, real big survey of research about 20 years ago was make up about 50% of people. Research more recently in smaller sample sizes seems to show that that number is declining quite rapidly, closer to about 30% of people are securely attached. And they statistically do the best in relationships, but again, that's roughly maybe 30% of people overall that are secure attachment styles. So then we have the other three. On one side, there's the anxious preoccupied, the anxiously attached style.
因此，根据大约20年前最后一次真正的大规模研究调查，安全依恋的个体在统计上约占人们的50%。最近在更小的样本量中的研究似乎表明，这个数字正在相当迅速地下降，更接近大约30%的人是安全依恋的。他们在统计上在关系中做得最好，但同样，这大约占总体人数的30%左右是安全依恋风格。然后我们还有其他三个。在一边，有焦虑担忧型，即焦虑依恋风格。
you can think of it as. And essentially the anxious attachment cell, what they do is in their childhood, they have a lot of love and care, but a lot of inconsistency around it. So a really common example would be that like both parents are very loving, but they work a lot. And so the child has a lot of love, but the parents are constantly coming and going, that maybe the child's staying with the grandparents who they're not as close with. And so the child keeps having love that's given and then taken away, love that's given and then taken away. And what's really interesting about that is how the subconscious mind gets programmed is through repetition and emotion. So if you have this repeated experience of love being given and then love being taken, it actually conditions into the
你可以这样想。基本上，焦虑的依恋风格，他们在童年时期有很多爱和关怀，但周围有很多不一致性。一个非常常见的例子是，父母双方都非常慈爱，但他们工作很多。所以孩子有很多爱，但父母经常来来往往，也许孩子和不太亲近的祖父母住在一起。所以孩子不断地得到爱然后被剥夺，得到爱然后被剥夺。关于这一点，非常有趣的是潜意识是如何通过重复和情绪被编程的。所以如果你有这种反复体验到爱被给予然后爱被剥夺的经历，它实际上会在
subconscious mind of fear of abandonment. And so anxiously attached individuals as adults, really fear abandonment, really fear of being alone, fear being not good enough or excluded or disliked. And they really try as a coping mechanism to maintain proximity to the people that they love. They try to hold on really tight. And sometimes that can make them a little bit clinging in relationships. And then on the far other end of the continuum, we have dismissive avoidant attachment style, who's pretty much the opposite, they grow up with some form of childhood emotional neglect. And what that means is that essentially even if food is on the table, even if it's not like overt neglect, it's more like under the radar neglect, we'll see that
潜意识中形成对被抛弃的恐惧。因此，作为成年人的焦虑依恋个体，真的很害怕被抛弃，真的很害怕独自一人，害怕不够好、被排斥或不被喜欢。他们真的试图作为一种应对机制来保持与他们所爱的人的亲密关系。他们试图抓得非常紧。有时这会使他们在关系中有点粘人。而在连续体的另一端，我们有冷漠疏离型依恋风格，这几乎是相反的，他们在某种形式的童年情感忽视中长大。这意味着，基本上即使桌上有食物，即使这不是明目张胆的忽视，它更像是雷达底下的忽视，我们会看到
the dismissive avoidant essentially like because children are wired for connection, for attunement, if a child growing up who's yearning for that connection, that present, from their caregivers doesn't have it. They just go, okay, well, it hurts to be this vulnerable and to feel like my needs won't get met. So I'm going to adapt to this by just denying that I need connection from other people. And so dismissive avoidance, push all their feelings down. They actually get conditioned to think because of their feelings not being made space for. They get conditioned to think that feelings are weak, useless, negative in some way.
疏离型依恋者基本上就像因为儿童是为连接、为调谐而生，如果一个渴望这种连接、这种来自照顾者的呈现的成长中的孩子没有得到它。他们只会说，好吧，表现得这么脆弱并觉得我的需求不会得到满足是很痛的。所以我将通过否认我需要来自其他人的连接来适应这一点。因此，疏离型依恋者压抑了他们所有的感受。他们实际上被训练成认为，因为他们的感受没有被腾出空间。他们被训练成认为感受在某种程度上是软弱的、无用的、消极的。
So they deny and reject that part of themselves. They think that part of themselves is almost like defect. in a way and they shove it down and because of that as adults they're terrified of getting too close to people they're terrified of like opening up getting too close feeling like they did as a child feeling weak and vulnerable with their emotional needs couldn't get met and so as adults they often like cut and cut relationships out when things get real um they'll tend to like be afraid of commitment or just when things are getting too close they'll run the other direction so that's our dismissive avoidant and then very last but not least um this is the least common attachment
所以他们否认和拒绝他们自己的那部分。他们认为自己的那部分几乎像是有缺陷。以某种方式，他们把它压下去了，正因为如此，作为成年人，他们害怕与人走得太近，他们害怕像敞开心扉、靠得太近、感觉像小时候那样、在情感需求无法得到满足时感到软弱和脆弱。因此，当事情变得真实时，作为成年人，他们经常会切断和切断关系，嗯，他们往往会害怕承诺，或者只是当事情靠得太近时，他们会朝相反的方向跑。所以这就是我们的疏离型依恋，然后最后但并非最不重要的一点，嗯，这是最不常见的依恋
style, but I think it is statistically more common than people probably realize is the fearful avoidant. So the fearful avoidant grows up in a household where there's basically extreme conditions. So let's say, for example, that there's tons of fighting in the house, right? So you never know what you're going to get. You come home. Sometimes it's peace. Sometimes it's chaos. Sometimes mom is in a good mood. Sometimes that's in a terrible mood. Sometimes it's flipped. Or another really common example for what creates a fearful avoidant attachment style is that we might have a peace. parent, for example, who's an alcoholic. So let's just say, like, one day mom is drinking, child, the mom comes home, child's his mom, she's in a good mood. She's had a few drinks.
风格，但我认为它在统计上比人们可能意识到的更常见，那就是恐惧疏离型。所以恐惧疏离型在一个基本上存在极端条件的环境中长大。比方说，举个例子，家里有成吨的争吵，对吧？所以你永远不知道你会得到什么。你回家。有时是平静。有时是混乱。有时妈妈心情好。有时那是糟糕的心情。有时是相反的。或者另一个关于是什么创造了恐惧疏离依恋风格的非常常见的例子是，我们可能有一个平静的。父母，例如，是个酒鬼。所以让我们假设，就像，有一天妈妈在喝酒，孩子，妈妈回家，孩子是他的妈妈，她心情很好。她喝了几杯。
She's super loving and in a great mood. Then another day mom comes home, she's had way too many drinks and she's an angry drunk today. Another day mom's sobering up. She feels guilty. She's being kind. Another day mom's sobering up. She's going through withdrawal. She's in a terrible mood. So fearful of going to grow up in this space where, number one, they get conflicting ideas about love, something that sometimes has really nice experiences, sometimes has really terrifying experiences. So they want love, but they are afraid of it at the same time. And also, they feel like they never know what they're going to get. So they're super hypervigilant, always walking on eggshells. They kind of struggle to trust in relationships and they're very
她超级有爱心，心情很好。然后另一天妈妈回家，她喝了太多酒，今天是个爱生气的酒鬼。另一天妈妈在醒酒。她感到内疚。她很善良。另一天妈妈在醒酒。她正在经历戒断反应。她心情极差。所以恐惧疏离型在这个空间长大，第一，他们对爱产生了矛盾的想法，有时有非常美好的体验，有时有非常可怕的体验。所以他们想要爱，但同时又害怕爱。而且，他们觉得他们永远不知道自己会得到什么。所以他们超级高度警惕，总是如履薄冰。他们在关系中很难信任，而且他们非常
hot and cold. It's like, come get close to me. Come get close. You get close and it's like, no, I changed my mind. Get away. And so they're very hot and cold and they actually share attributes of both the anxious and avoidance side. But they go back and forth between those sides on a really, really frequent basis. That is such a good summary. I'm like listening to that. And the point you made about parents who like work a lot is so valuable because I think often we just tend to imagine that it's extreme trauma that creates anything but a secure attachment style but it really is just any kind of inconsistencies as you said in the the love and the compassion and the and the support that we're shown I want to ask you something here that
时冷时热。这就好像是在说：快来靠近我，快来靠近。当你靠近了，他们却又像是在说：不了，我改变主意了，走开。所以他们表现得非常时冷时热，实际上兼具了焦虑型和回避型两者的特征。但他们会在这些特征之间非常、非常频繁地来回切换。这真是一个极好的总结。我听着这些，联想到你提到的关于经常工作的父母的观点，真的非常有价值，因为我认为通常我们往往倾向于认为，只有极端的创伤才会导致安全型依恋之外的任何其他依恋风格，但实际上，正如你所说，这真的只是在向我们展示的爱、同情和支持中，存在任何形式的不一致。在这里我想问你一件事，
has been on my mind, like, a lot. Is it just childhood experiences that create your attachment style, or can it equally be molded by early relationship experiences or even, like, recent relationship experiences? Amazing question. So we're not born with an attachment style. It forms over time based on, like, the conditions we're repeatedly exposed to. So because as children, we basically, like,
这个问题一直以来都在我脑海里盘旋。到底是童年经历塑造了你的依恋风格，还是早期的人际关系经历，甚至就像是最近的人际关系经历，也能同样重塑它？这是一个非常棒的问题。首先，我们天生并没有特定的依恋风格。它是随着时间推移，根据我们反复接触的环境逐渐形成的。因为作为孩子，我们基本上处于一种
we're sort of in what we can call a hyper suggestible state, meaning that we are like really sponging up all of our programs in childhood. We're very impressionable. A lot of our programming runs deep. So our childhood attachment style is formed at a very early age and it often sticks with us for quite some time. But anything we are repeatedly exposed to for long enough that causes a big impact, again, that like repetition and emotion is what programs a subconscious mind,
我们可以称之为高度易受暗示的状态，这意味着在童年时期，我们真的像海绵一样在吸收所有的程序。我们非常容易受影响，许多底层程序都植根很深。所以我们的童年依恋风格在很小的年龄就形成了，并且往往会伴随我们相当长的一段时间。但是，任何我们长期反复接触并产生重大影响的事物——再次强调，这种“重复加上情感”正是对潜意识进行编程的关键，
then it can absolutely reprogram our attachment style. So for example, somebody could be secure, see their parents go through a really awful divorce at 15, and that could make them fearful, avoidant, or anxious. Or another example is you could be anxiously attached, get into a relationship with a narcissist. At the end of that relationship, you're now a fearful avoidant because there's a lot more substantial chaos and trauma. So our attachment cell can absolutely change, but you can think of the prerequisite as being, it's less likely to be one experience that changes it, but more for your attachment cell to change. there has to be a lot of repeated exposure to something different.
那么它绝对可以重新对我们的依恋风格进行编程。举个例子，一个人原本可能是安全型的，但在15岁时目睹父母经历了一场非常糟糕的离婚，这可能会使他们变得恐惧回避型或焦虑型。或者另一个例子，你可能是焦虑型依恋，结果和水仙花人格（自恋者）谈了恋爱。在那段关系结束时，你现在变成了一个恐惧回避型，因为其中存在着多得多的实质性混乱和创伤。所以我们的依恋风格绝对是可以改变的，但你可以这样理解它的前提条件：单单某一次经历去改变它的可能性较小，而要想让你的依恋风格发生改变，必须有对某种不同事物的很多次反复接触。
That's really important to note. It's the repetition that really counts. It's not like you've had, you've been ghosted one time by someone on a dating app and suddenly you're like an anxious avoidant. Like it's a repeat kind of experience. So I really want to focus on the anxious attachment style here. Because as you said, we have secure. That's the most common.
这一点非常重要，需要指出。真正起作用的是“重复”。并不是说你在约会软件上被人“放鸽子”（断联）了一次，然后你突然就变成了一个焦虑回避型。这是一种重复性质的体验。所以在这里我真的很想把重点放在焦虑型依恋风格上。因为正如你所说，我们有安全型，这是最常见的。
Anxious is the second most common. and it's increasing in prevalence, probably a lot in this current generation. I have two questions for you. A, why do you think that is? And B, what does that, what kind of consequences does that have for how we approach dating? Really great question. So I think there's two, there's a couple of reasons, right? I think one of the biggest ones, just quite honestly, is like kind of cultural at this point.
焦虑型是第二常见的，而且它的流行率还在不断上升，在当今这一代人中可能尤其如此。我有两个问题想问你：A，你认为这是为什么？B，这对于我们对待约会的方式有什么样的影响？非常棒的问题。所以我认为有两个，有几个原因吧。我认为其中最大的原因之一，坦白讲，在这一点上有点像是文化层面的原因。
in a lot of the Western world at least, but, you know, really the vast majority of the world as a whole, unfortunately, there's a lot of pressure, right? So we don't have what we had 20 years ago, 30 years ago, 40 years ago, where we had one parent able to stay home. And one of the biggest impactors for what creates somebody's attachment style is the amount of presence they have. And I don't mean like gifts. I mean like the amount of attunement, the person, the parent being physically present. And, you know, because we have usually both parents working in a household nowadays, a lot of that kind of, you know, even if the parents and caregivers are loving, often children have to go to daycare young.
至少在许多西方世界里，但老实说，不幸的是，确实是世界上绝大多数地方，都有很大的压力。所以我们没有20年前、30年前、40年前那种可以由一方父母全职在家的条件了。而决定一个人依恋风格的最主要影响因素之一，就是陪伴的多少。我指的不是礼物，我指的是情感协调的程度，也就是父母身体在场的程度。你知道的，因为现在通常家里双职工都在工作，所以很多这样的情况，即使父母和照顾者很有爱，孩子们也常常很早就得去托儿所。
And, you know, that's not me saying anything towards parents, like usually because of societal pressures, like literally there's no choice. But you can see how that context is sort of being set. The stage is being set to create more anxiously attached children because they don't have as much connection and care coming from their parents in the same way. because it's literally not possible for the vast majority of people. And I think what happens is because of that, what you'll see is anxiously attached individuals.
你知道的，我这么说并不是针对父母，通常是因为社会压力，字面意思上说就是别无选择。但你可以看到这种背景正在被这样设定。这种环境正在酝酿出更多焦虑型依恋的孩子，因为他们没有从父母那里获得同样多质的连接和关爱，因为对于绝大多数人来说这字面意义上就是不可能做到的。我认为发生的情况是，正因为如此，你会发现焦虑型依恋的个体们。
It's like they really, one of their biggest challenges that they'll have with dating is that they don't properly bet what they want because they get too busy people pleasing. So when I would have clients who would come to me from different attachments, I was back when I was running my practice, I would often have dismissive avoidance they would sit down
这就好像他们在约会时遇到的最大挑战之一，就是他们没有正确地对想要的对象进行背景调查或筛选，因为他们太忙于讨好别人了。所以过去当我有不同依恋类型的客户来找我时——那是当我还在经营我的诊所的时候——我经常会接待那些疏离回避型的客户，他们坐在那里
and they would be like too picky. you know, as soon as they saw one flaw, they'd run in the other direction in dating. And then we'd have anxiously attached individuals who are not picky enough. They're not like getting clear on what they're looking for, what they really want in a relationship, what their standards are. So rather than properly vetting somebody when they were dating, they would find somebody who's interested in them. As long as I thought that person was moderately attractive and they moderately got along with them, they would then spend that whole first dating stage of the relationship, trying to win the person over through people pleasing, through you know, sort of putting on their best behavior all the time, rather than by being like, is this person actually a good fit for me? And rather than expressing their needs and talking about
就会显得非常挑剔。你知道的，一旦他们发现一个缺点，他们在约会时就会往反方向逃跑。然后我们会遇到那些不够挑剔的焦虑型依恋个体。他们没有搞清楚自己在寻找什么，在一段关系中真正想要的是什么，他们的标准是什么。因此，在约会时，他们没有去适当地筛选对方，而是只要找到一个对他们感兴趣的人。只要他们觉得这个人还算有吸引力，并且和自己还能合得来，他们就会把关系的整个初期约会阶段，都用来试图通过讨好别人来赢得这个人的芳心，通过展现自己总是表现得最好的一面，而不是去思考“这个人真的适合我吗”，也不是去表达自己的需求并讨论
their boundaries and seeing if that person was a good fit into their lives as well. And there's a huge impact in dating that way because we're not picking the right potential partners. And also, people statistically are less attracted to people pleasers than they are to people sense of self. And so we may not realize that I think anxious preoccupant individuals kind of think that like, if I'm people pleasing and I'm more agreeable and I say yes to everything, that, oh, then we get along and then everything's easy and then I'll be liked and accepted and I'll win them over. But actually, it usually works against them if they don't have this appropriate set of standards for themselves. They say what's okay with them and what's not okay with them. And if they're not backing themselves,
他们的界限，看看这个人是否也能很好地融入他们的生活。这种约会方式产生了巨大的影响，因为我们没有挑选出合适的潜在伴侣。而且，从统计学上讲，人们对讨好型人格的吸引力，要小于对那些有自我意识的人的吸引力。所以我们可能没有意识到，我认为焦虑预占型的个体可能觉得：如果我在讨好别人，我更好相处，我对所有事情都说“好”，哦，那我们就能合得来，一切都会很轻松，然后我就会被喜欢、被接受，我会赢得他们的心。但实际上，如果他们没有为自己设定一套适当的标准，这通常会对他们产生反作用。他们要说出什么对他们来说是可以接受的，什么是不可以接受的。如果他们不坚定地支持自己，
statistically people are actually less attracted to that overall. That makes a lot of sense. I think it's, it makes sense, but it's also so unfair because if you think about the people who, people please, like often it does come from a very deep like childhood abandonment wound or a guilt wound where, yeah, where you feel like I need to make everybody else happy because otherwise I am unsafe and because otherwise I do not get the connection and the attachment that I crave. So when it comes to these kind of like people pleasing tendencies, you firstly mention that sometimes it results in us choosing partners who might actually in the long term not be right for us, might not actually be a good match.
从统计数据来看，人们整体上其实对这种行为更不感兴趣。这非常合理。我认为这说得通，但同时也太不公平了，因为如果你想想那些讨好别人的人，通常它确实源于一种非常深层的童年被抛弃的创伤或负罪感创伤，在那种创伤中，你会觉得“我需要让其他人高兴，否则我是不安全的，否则我就无法获得我渴望的连接和依恋”。所以当谈到这种讨好别人的倾向时，你首先提到的是，有时这会导致我们选择在长期来看可能并不适合我们、可能并非真正好伴侣的人。
What does it then look like when we get into the relationship past the first, you know, honeymoon period where everyone's on their best behavior, everyone's trying to win the other person over? when you get deeper into the relationship, assuming this person is actually right for you, what kind of starts to show up in our behavior? Amazing question. These are fantastic questions. So before I dive into that, just for a moment, I want to say one other thing, because you said something really powerful, which is that when, you know, it's sort of unfair,
那么，当我们进入一段关系，度过了最初的、每个人都表现得最好、每个人都试图赢得对方好感的“蜜月期”之后，情况会是怎样的呢？当你更深入地进入关系时，假设这个人其实真的很适合你，我们的行为开始显现出什么样的情况？非常棒的问题。这些都是极其精彩的问题。所以在我深入探讨之前，我想先花一点时间说另一件事，因为你刚才说了一个非常有力观点：当
because when somebody is, like, trying to people please, it's coming from, this deep childhood trauma is actually what it is, like this abandonment wound of feeling afraid of being out on their own and then being unsafe or being disliked or rejected. And when anxious individuals are actually feeling anxiously attached, like when that anxious attachment and they're needing to call or text or maintain proximity, when they're feeling like that, I think something that's understated is that that's actually a trauma response for somebody. That's actually them when you feel that panic in your body and your conscious mind knows better, like don't call them again or give them space or you have to put your phone in the other room and shut it off or, you know, these kinds of things.
当一个人试图讨好别人时，它是源于这种深层的童年创伤，实际情况正是如此，这是一种害怕独自一人然后变得不安全、或者不被喜欢或拒绝的“被遗弃创伤”。当焦虑型个体真正感受到焦虑型依恋时——也就是当那种焦虑型依恋发作，他们需要打电话、发短信或保持亲密关系时，当他们有这种感觉时，我认为有一个被低估的事实是，这实际上是某人的创伤反应。这实际上是当你的身体感到恐慌，而你的理智明知不该这样做（比如不要再给他打电话了，或者给彼此留出空间，或者你得把手机放到另一个房间并关掉，或者诸如此类的事情），
and yet you can't help it and eventually do make that phone call again or eventually do reach back out. That's actually a trauma response. And so there is something disheartening about that. And at the same time, I think it's really important to look at the sort of silver lining of it too, which is that exactly what you need to do to be successful in dating is also exactly what you need to do to heal yourself and to feel better and actually heal from those childhood wounds. So with the acknowledgement of that stuff, and I'm sure we can get into all that stuff in a little bit, like what that looks like, but just with the acknowledgement of like this really sucks that I have these wounds and they're painful, at the same time noticing them and acknowledging them and being able to work through them in your dating life will also help you feel so much more secure and confident and at peace within yourself. So it's very healing. So it's like a crisis and an opportunity, if that makes sense. So going back to what you were talking about, basically an anxious attack. style in a relationship has a few core things. So they will tend to, in that dating stage specifically,
然而你却情不自禁，最终还是拨通了那个电话，或者最终还是重新联系了对方。这其实是一种创伤反应。所以这其中确实有些令人沮丧的事情。但与此同时，我认为看到它积极光明的一面也非常重要，那就是：在约会中获得成功所需要做的事情，恰恰也是治愈你自己、感觉更好并真正从那些童年创伤中恢复过来所需要做的事情。因此，在承认了这些事情之后——我确信我们很快就会深入探讨所有这些内容，比如它看起来是什么样的——但在承认“我有这些创伤且它们很痛苦，这真的很糟糕”的同时，去注意到它们、承认它们，并能够在你的约会生活中克服它们，也将帮助你感到内心更加安全、自信和宁静。所以这非常具有治愈意义。因此，如果可以这样理解的话，它既是一场危机，也是一个机遇。所以回到你刚才谈到的，基本上焦虑型依恋风格在恋爱关系中有几个核心特征。所以他们往往会在那个约会阶段特别倾向于，
start, you know, people pleasing, trying to win the person over. And if anybody who's listening is not familiar, we actually have six stages of a relationship. So we start off with a dating stage, which is actually meant to be the bedding stage. Then we go into the honeymoon stage of a relationship. And that's that like honeymoon period, but the mask is usually still on during that period. after that when people start getting more comfortable they start dropping the mask and that becomes the power struggle stage every relationship has one and the more you are people pleasing and not being yourself in the dating and honeymoon stage the harder the power struggle stage will be um and then after the power struggle stage if we make it through the rights of passage which are really about being vulnerable
开始（你知道的）讨好别人，试图赢得对方的芳心。如果任何在听节目的朋友对此不熟悉，我们实际上把恋爱关系分为六个阶段。所以我们从约会阶段开始，这个阶段实际上应该是筛选阶段。然后我们进入关系的蜜月阶段。那就是所谓的蜜月期，但通常在这个时期面具仍然戴着。在那之后，当人们开始感到更加舒适时，他们开始摘下面具，这就成为了权力争夺阶段。每段关系都有这样一个阶段，你在约会和蜜月阶段越是讨好别人、越是没有做自己，权力争夺阶段就会越艰难；
and learning to show ourselves and share ourselves with our partners then we get into the stability stage then that's followed by the commitment stage where we start talking about really long-term commitments marriage, children, living together, et cetera. And then we get to the bliss stage, which is like the honeymoon stage, but where you actually deeply know each other. So what happens for a lot of anxious attachments to your earlier point is that we can get into a place where it's like you're so busy trying to win the person over and be on your best behavior that you don't ever share who you really are, what your real needs
然后，在权力争夺阶段之后，如果我们通过了真正的考验（这实际上是关于变得脆弱，
are in a relationship. And if you do share them, you share them retroactively. So rather than saying like, hey, I could use some support. Can you do the dishes? It's like, hey, I hold that in. I don't ever ask for the support. And then finally one day I'm like, you never do the dishes. And then, you know, that doesn't land with somebody that we care about because they just feel
并在关系中学习向伴侣展现自我和分享自我），那么我们就进入了稳定阶段。接下来是承诺阶段，我们开始讨论真正长期的承诺，比如结婚、生子、同居等等。然后我们到达了美满（极乐）阶段，这就像蜜月阶段一样，但此时你们已经真正深入地了解了彼此。所以，正如你之前所提到的，对于许多焦虑型依恋者来说，会发生的情况是：你们可能会陷入这样一种境地，即你整天忙着试图赢得对方的芳心并表现出最好的一面，以至于你从未分享过真正的自我，以及你在关系中的真实需求
criticized because anxiously attached people, even though we think that they're so emotionally available, people pleasing is not an emotionally available thing. People pleasing is I'm hiding, right? I'm not truly being myself. I'm not sharing myself with you out of a fear of rejection. And so that's going to cause me something in the power struggle stage. And so what ends up taking place is as an anxious attachment style, They usually, you know, sort of date.
是什么。如果你确实分享了，你也是在事后才分享的。所以，与其说“嘿，我需要一些支持，你能洗碗吗？”，情况往往是“嘿，我把这个憋在心里，我从来不寻求支持”。然后终于有一天我说：“你从来不洗碗！”接着，你知道的，这并不能被我们关心的人接受，因为他们只会觉得自己
So they're so good at trying to win people over in the dating and honeymoon stage. And then when the power struggle comes on, they really see a lot of turbulence in their relationships at that point. And what they'll start to see is that they feel really unseen by their partners, unheard, like their needs don't matter. Sometimes they can feel resentful because they're usually like pouring into the relationship with somebody and then feeling like they're not getting their needs met back. Then that can cause them to be slightly critical in their communication,
受到了批评。因为焦虑型依恋的人，尽管我们认为他们在情感上是可及的，但讨好别人并不是一种情感上可及的表现。讨好别人意味着“我在隐藏”，对吧？我并没有真正做自己。由于害怕被拒绝，我没有把自己展现给你。因此，这会在权力争夺阶段给我带来一些问题。所以最终发生的事情是，作为一个焦虑型依恋风格者，他们通常（你知道的）去约会。
which then often causes the other person to just shut down. and meet their needs even less than they already are. And then we'll often see anxious, preoccupied attachment styles have a lot of fears come up when they see their partner pull back and then try to sort of maintain that proximity, try to get closer. And often we can get stuck in these like cycles where we keep trying to get closer, the person pulls away, keep trying to get closer, the person pulls away. And it can be really painful for the anxiously attached style, especially in the power struggle
所以在约会和蜜月阶段，他们非常擅长试图赢得别人的芳心。然后当权力争夺阶段来临时，他们在人际关系中确实会看到很多动荡。他们开始注意到的是，他们觉得自己在伴侣眼中变得很不显眼、不被倾听，好像他们的需求根本不重要。有时他们会感到怨恨，因为他们通常把精力倾注在某人身上，然后觉得自己的需求没有得到回报。接着，这会导致他们在沟通中变得稍微有些批判性，
stage of relationships. So in the power struggle stage, what are we like most likely to see? because I have not heard about this before. I knew about, obviously, the honeymoon stage and the bliss stage, but I've never heard about this power struggle moment. So the power struggle stage, statistically is the stage where most people break up in relationships. And it is one of the most challenging stages, but again, I really find it to be. It's like the same thing, right?
而这通常又会导致对方直接选择关闭心扉，甚至比以前更少去满足他们的需求。然后我们经常会看到，焦虑预占型依恋风格在看到伴侣退缩时会涌现出很多恐惧，然后又试图去维持那种亲密感，试图靠得更近。而且我们往往会陷入这种循环中：我们不断试图靠近，对方却推开；我们继续试图靠近，对方又推开。这对于焦虑型依恋风格的人来说会非常痛苦，尤其是在关系的权力争夺
It's like a crisis and an opportunity. It's really hard, and it also presents the most opportunity for building really deep roots in a relationship. So in the power struggle, one of the rights of passage to make it out of the power struggle is being vulnerable with our partners, really letting somebody see us, like what our real fears are, what our concerns are for anxious preoccupies. It involves things like, you know, sharing that sometimes they need reassurance or sometimes they need certainty, you know, letting their partner know if you cancel plans. I'm okay with plans canceled sometimes, but try to rebook them or tell me when we're going to meet next or, you know, so them asking for, hey, I can be flexible, but I still need you to see that these are my needs. and these are the things that are important to me. So it really requires a lot of expression vulnerability about their needs, about their fears.
阶段。所以在权力争夺阶段，我们最有可能看到的是什么呢？因为我以前没听说过这个。我当然知道蜜月阶段和美满阶段，但我从未听说过这个权力争夺的时刻。所以，权力争夺阶段从统计学上讲是大多数人在恋爱关系中分手的阶段。它是最具挑战性的阶段之一，但再次说明，我真的发现它很有意义。它就像是同一件事，对吧？
And what that opportunity becomes is when I lower my mask and I start sharing who I am with you without conditions, I now present the opportunity to be loved in a more unconditional way. Because when I'm only sharing who I am with conditions, you can only love me conditionally. That's all I make space for.
它既是一场危机，也是一个机遇。它真的很艰难，同时也为在一段关系中建立深厚的根基提供了最多的机会。所以在权力争夺阶段，要想闯过这一关所需的必经考验之一，就是对伴侣展现脆弱，真正让别人看到我们——我们的真实恐惧是什么，对于焦虑预占型的人来说，我们的担忧是什么。这包括诸如（你知道的）分享他们有时需要安慰，或者有时需要确定感，让他们的伴侣知道：如果取消计划——我有时可以接受取消计划，但尽量重新预约，或者告诉我我们下次什么时候见面——或者（你知道的）让他们提出：“嘿，我可以灵活调整，但我仍然需要你看到这些是我的需求，这些是对我很重要的事情。”所以这确实需要大量地表达关于他们需求和恐惧的脆弱性。
And so what's going to end up happening is I'm going to constantly, if I was anxiously attached, feel this sense of like, you don't see me, you don't hear me, you don't really care about me, and it'll feel defeating and saddening. But if instead we can drop the mask, we can share in a healthy way, be more vulnerable, gain that acceptance from our partner and also have our partner do the same thing. That's where we now build real roots in a relationship where we can really deepen love and what it means to be loved. And that sets us up for success in the future stages.
所以最终发生的情况是，如果我是焦虑型依附，我会不断地感受到一种“你看不见我，你听不见我，你根本不在乎我”的感觉，这会让人感到挫败和悲伤。但如果我们能放下伪装，以健康的方式分享，变得更加脆弱，从伴侣那里获得这种接纳，并让伴侣也这样做。这就是我们在关系中建立真正根基的地方，在这里我们可以真正深化爱以及被爱的意义。这也为我们在未来的阶段取得成功奠定了基础。
So it's tricky. And we'll generally see the most fighting in the power struggle stage, most bickering arguments, push-pull kind of behaviors, but if we can do it properly, we also see tremendous success coming up on the other side. It's so fascinating to hear you say that because I think I'm applying that to my own relationship, and we were speaking about this before we started recording about how I think I used to be someone who was very anxiously attached, and then I met someone who really challenged me and in the best ways possible and, like, challenged me with healthy love such that the little tendencies that up the defensive mechanisms, like they just didn't work anymore. I used to always have this sense
所以这很棘手。我们通常会在权力争夺阶段看到最多的争吵、最多的挑剔和争论、拉锯战般的行为，但如果我们能妥善处理，我们也会在另一面看到巨大的成功。听到你这么说太迷人了，因为我想我正在把这一点应用到我自己的感情中，我们在录音前也讨论过这个，我觉得我以前是一个极度焦虑型依附的人，然后我遇到了一个真正挑战我的人，而且是用尽可能最好的方式，用健康的爱来挑战我，以至于那些触发防御机制的小倾向，比如它们根本不管用了。我以前总是有一种
of like, it was almost like a game, right? I was like, I don't want you to leave me. I don't want you to not reply to my messages, so I'm not going to reply to yours. And he was like, no, we're not playing those games anymore. Why are you feeling so anxious about this? Like, let's have a discussion. And it was so hard. Like, it was actually really difficult. in that stage to force myself to be vulnerable and to be like, I'm experiencing a lot of anxiety right now that you're going to walk away, that you're going to leave me, that small thing where you didn't hug me, when you first walked through the door,
这种感觉，几乎就像一场游戏，对吧？我想：我不想让你离开我。我不想让你不回复我的消息，所以我也不回复你的消息。而他说：不，我们不再玩那些游戏了。你为什么对此感到这么焦虑？我们来讨论一下。这太难了。在那个阶段，强迫自己变得脆弱并说“我现在感到非常焦虑，担心你会离开我，担心你刚进门时没有拥抱我那件小事，
that was a really, it was a really huge alarm bell for me. And it was so, like I said, difficult, but I always think that vulnerability is met with huge, emotional, personal, social, relationship reward because you're showing up as yourself and you're being like, I'm going to do the hard thing here. I'm going to be incredibly open with this person, knowing that they could say the wrong thing, but taking that risk anyways. And I do always think that you come out the other side with a lot, a better understanding at least of who that person is. 100%. And, you know, it's real. Like the fear is real when you have those conversations. Like I can remember the first time I was a
那对我来说真的是一个巨大的警报”。正如我所说，这非常困难，但我一直认为，脆弱会带来巨大的情感、个人、社交和关系上的回报，因为你表现真实的自己，并且你在想：我要在这里做困难的事。我要对这个人无比坦诚，尽管我知道他们可能会说错话，但无论如何我都要冒这个险。我一直认为，你从另一面走出来时，会有很多收获，至少能更好地了解那个人是谁。百分之百。而且，你知道，这是真的。当你进行这些对话时，恐惧是真实的。我记得第一次我是一个
fearful avoidant attachment. I can remember the first time I shared about having a fear in a relationship about, but it was with my now husband. But at the time, we were going through like sort of our own power struggle and I had to open up and share that I had this fear of something sort of similar. Mine was like more about like betrayal. And, and it was funny because it was not really based on anything at the time except my own stories about something. But I remember being so terrified thinking, oh my gosh, I can't believe I'm sharing this with somebody and scared of feeling weak or rejected or too vulnerable. But it's like the change when we learn to do that work is so beautiful because, you know, if we're in a relationship with somebody we vet it a little bit and
恐惧型回避依附者。我记得第一次在一段关系中分享恐惧，但那是和我现在的丈夫。不过当时，我们正在经历某种程度的权力争夺，我必须敞开心扉，分享我内心对类似事情的恐惧。我的恐惧更多是关于背叛的。有趣的是，当时这其实并没有什么根据，除了我自己编造的一些故事。但我记得当时非常害怕，心想：天哪，我不敢相信我正在和别人分享这些，害怕显得软弱、被拒绝或过于脆弱。但事实是，当我们学会做这项工作时，这种改变是如此美好，因为，你知道，如果我们和一个我们稍微考察过、
who's a good fit, people respond way more than I think we imagine because as a child, if you couldn't get your needs met, that's all your programming. You're like, oh, well, then my needs will not be met. So I have to keep people pleasing or I have to keep holding back and not saying anything. And so we assume that onto our partners. We tend to project that onto our present, if that was our experience as children. But as an adult, it's actually very different, right? We can communicate differently. We can share things more. We have emotional literacy. We can talk things out in a different way that we didn't have access to as a child. So we get to heal all of these different underlying programs. And when we communicate our needs, we actually give ourselves
并且很合适的人建立关系，人们的反应远比我们想象的要多得多，因为作为孩子，如果你无法满足自己的需求，这就是你所有的编程。你会想：哦，好吧，那我的需求将无法得到满足。所以我必须继续讨好别人，或者我必须继续隐忍，什么也不说。于是我们把这种心态投射到伴侣身上。如果我们童年有过这种经历，我们往往会把它投射到现在的关系中。但作为成年人，其实非常不同，对吧？我们可以用不同的方式沟通。我们可以分享更多的事情。我们拥有情感素养。我们可以用一种在小时候无法接触到的不同方式来把事情谈透。所以我们得以治愈所有这些不同的底层程序。当我们表达自己的需求时，我们实际上给了自己
the opportunity to have people show up for us. And I can share from my experience. I'm curious about yours. But for me, one of the most beautiful things I learned is that when I actually shared about my needs and I actually took the courage and the risk of being vulnerable, I actually felt so much more loved by all the people in my life because they really did show up and they weren't perfect. And if they weren't perfect, I could go back and have a conversation again. But like, I couldn't believe how much I actually felt like I could receive love from other people when I did that. And I'm curious to hear if you felt that as well. 100%. And not just in terms of my partner. Like I remember having like this conversation with him where I was like these are my fears and then looking at him afterwards and being like, oh right.
让别人为我们付出的机会。我可以分享我的经历。我也很好奇你的经历。但对我来说，我学到的最美好的事情之一是，当我真正说出我的需求，并且鼓起勇气去冒脆弱的风险时，我实际上从生命中的所有人那里感到了更多的爱，因为他们确实付出了，而且他们并不完美。如果他们不完美，我可以回头再进行一次对话。但是，当我这样做时，我简直不敢相信自己竟然能感受到从其他人那里接收到这么多的爱。我很想知道你是否也有这种感觉。百分之百。而且不仅仅是对我的伴侣。就像我记得和他进行过这样的对话，当时我说：这些是我的恐惧，然后看着他，心想：哦，对了。
So like this is what the next stage of our love looks like and being like I'm so in love with you right now because you met me here. And it was also something that I started doing with my friends. So I had a lot of anxiety around friendships fizzling out. This preoccupation with this idea that my friends really didn't like me. didn't want to be around me, like, and or I would just experience a lot of loneliness, even when it was unjustified. And I remember there was like this light bulb moment, and it may seem so common sense to people listening to this who are already applying these tactics, but I just like, message my friend and was like, I am just feeling really low right now.
所以，这就是我们爱情下一阶段的样子，然后心想：我现在太爱你了，因为你在此时此地接住了我。这也是我开始和朋友们做的事情。我对友谊的消逝感到非常焦虑。这种执念认为我的朋友们其实并不喜欢我，不想和我在一起，或者即使在毫无根据的时候，我也会感到非常孤独。我记得当时有一个恍然大悟的时刻，对于听这个节目、已经在应用这些策略的人来说，这可能看起来像常识，但我只是给我的朋友发了一条消息说：我现在的状态真的很低落。
And it's not that I'm feeling like everything in my life is great, but I just really need connection from you and I just really need you to call me and just like give me a bit of reassurance and she did it and she was like yeah let's do something this weekend let's go to the beach and it was this weird thing where you're exactly right as a child you don't know how to ask for that you can't be like hey mom can you stop working late because I've identified that I'm on the way to be being like anxiously attached like you're sometimes non-verbal like that's not a way that you can operate but then as you become an adult it's like wow it's so crazy to realize that especially as someone who maybe was anxious or any of those number of insecure attachment
并不是我觉得生活中的一切都很棒，但我真的需要你的陪伴，我真的需要你打电话给我，给我一点安慰。她真的这么做了，并且说：好啊，我们这周末做点什么吧，去海滩吧。这真是一件奇妙的事情，你说得完全没错，小的时候你不知道该如何开口要求，你不能说：嘿，妈妈，你能别工作到那么晚吗？因为我已经发现我正走在变得像焦虑型依附的路上，有时候你就是不会用语言表达，那不是你的运作方式。但当你长大成人后，你会想：哇，意识到这一点太疯狂了，特别是作为一个可能曾经感到焦虑、或者有任何这些不安全依附
styles, just speaking your needs a lot of the time means that they will be met. It's so beautiful. And I just love like talking about things like this because it's so powerful, like, you know, having also witnessed that firsthand with so many like friendships, family relationships, like how much we actually allow ourselves to be loved by people we care about so much when we do those things. And it's like such a rewarding experience. And for people who like maybe think of this like what if the person doesn't show up well that might happen but then those people aren't really meant to be in your inner circle anyways you know those people aren't meant to withstand the test of time in your life and it's worth building relationships with people that are it's worth
风格的人来说，很多时候，只要说出你的需求，就意味着它们会被满足。这太美妙了。我就是喜欢谈论这样的话题，因为它太有力量了，你知道的，亲眼目睹了许多友谊、家庭关系中发生的一切，当我们做这些事情时，我们实际上是多么允许自己被那些我们深切关心的人所爱。这真是一段充满回报的经历。对于那些可能会想“万一这个人没有付出怎么办”的人来说，那可能会发生，但那样的话，这些人无论如何也不属于你的核心圈子，你知道，这些人注定经不起你生命中时间的考验，但与那些经得起考验的人建立关系是值得的，去
going through figuring those things out so that you can have people around you who really do show up for you who really do care about you and i think as an anxious attachment so it's good to also practice showing up for ourselves like you know there's that part as well of self-soothing but I cannot stress enough how beautiful it is to practice that vulnerability piece. Absolutely. We're going to take a quick break, and when we come back, we're going to discuss the interactions between the anxious attachment style and the avoidant attachment style.
经历并弄清楚这些事情是值得的，这样你的周围才能真正有那些为你付出、真正关心你的人。我认为作为焦虑型依附者，同时练习为自己付出也是很好的，你知道，还有自我安抚的那一部分，但我怎么强调练习脆弱这一部分的美妙之处都不为过。绝对是的。我们将进行短暂的休息，回来后，我们将讨论焦虑型依附风格与回避型依附风格之间的相互作用。
We will be back with you very shortly. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
我们很快回来。百分之二。这是当自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健康以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on. on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊恐的许多问题其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一面成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。这就是在I-Hart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听的《TWO percent》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex In. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·尹。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他大谈80年代的快克。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在节目里谈论快克，只是想让你们都知道。我是说，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而我们仍在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You don't I doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
这是两个不同的信任级别。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的Our Heart Radio应用。搜索《吃一堑长一智》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露了她陈述中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律之战，旨在证明真相。你难道不……我伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·纳拉尼尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。
Something that I have learned recently is that the anxious attachment style is often attracted to the avoidant attachment style. whether that is fearful or dismissive. Why is that? Because that feels so counterintuitive. Surely the anxiously attached person would be most attracted to someone who is secure. But you were telling me that is not often the case. Yeah, it's an amazing question. So here's what happens.
我最近学到的一点是，焦虑型依附风格往往被回避型依附风格所吸引。无论是恐惧型还是疏离型。这是为什么呢？因为这太反直觉了。当然，焦虑型依附的人应该最被那些有安全感的人吸引。但你告诉我，情况往往并非如此。是的，这是一个极好的问题。所以情况是这样的。
So when we think of our attachment style, I want us to first think of the difference between like conscious and subconscious. So conscious mind, I'm sure everybody's had this experience in some way where they're like, their mind knows better. They're going, I know this is not. the right fit for me or I know I should leave this relationship that's not working or I know that this person's like not the guy I should be dating or not the woman that I should be, you know, and yet we repeat patterns. Well, that's the difference between our conscious and subconscious.
当我们想到自己的依附风格时，我希望我们首先考虑的是意识和潜意识之间的区别。所以意识层面，我确信每个人都有过这样的经历，他们的理智更清楚。他们会想：我知道这不是适合我的对象，或者我知道我应该离开这段没有结果的关系，或者我知道这个人不是我应该约会的人，或者不是我应该……你知道的，然而我们却在重复模式。这就是我们的意识和潜意识之间的区别。
Conscious mind can logically analyze and see things, but our subconscious is the one running the show. The subconscious is actually responsible for 95 to 97% of our beliefs or thoughts, our decisions, our emotions, our actions. So what happens is when we think of our attachment style, I like to get everybody in the habit of thinking of it as like the subconscious set of rules that you have about love. And when we look at tackling the subconscious, one thing that's really valuable to realize is that our subconscious mind's biggest priority is survival. So what this means is that anything that feels familiar feels safe and thus increases the chances that we're going to survive. And that's what the subconscious is seeking the most. So what's funny is that what our subconscious comfort zone is,
意识可以进行逻辑分析并看到事物，但潜意识才是幕后操纵者。潜意识实际上控制着我们95%到97%的信念或想法、决定、情绪和行动。所以发生的情况是，当我们想到自己的依附风格时，我喜欢让每个人习惯于把它看作是你关于爱的潜意识规则集。当我们着手处理潜意识时，有一点认识起来非常宝贵，那就是我们潜意识的最大首要任务是生存。这意味着任何感觉熟悉的东西都会让人感到安全，从而增加我们生存的机会。而这正是潜意识最在追求的。有趣的是，我们的潜意识舒适区是什么呢？
that sort of zone that our subconscious keeps wanting to keep us in and stay in, is actually that as an anxiously attached person, the relationship you have to yourself is to constantly dismiss and avoid your own feelings, needs, and desires in favor of pleasing other people, which means your subconscious comfort zone that you're used to operating in all day long is to put your needs last, feelings last, not really care about your own boundaries, not worry too much about you being a priority.
那种潜意识一直想要让我们保持在其中、留在其中的区域，实际上是作为一个焦虑型依附者，你对自己关系的模式是：为了取悦他人，不断地否定和回避自己的感受、需求和欲望，这意味着你习惯了一整天都在其中运作的潜意识舒适区，就是把自己的需求放在最后，把感受放在最后，并不真正关心自己的边界，也不太担心自己是否是第一位的。
And so that's that zone of familiarity and safety to your subconscious mind. So when we're starting to invest in people or we're dating people, guess what one of the biggest factors is that drives attraction? If somebody represents the subconscious comfort zone and the relationship we have to ourselves, which means that often anxiously attach people, even though they might see somebody be dismissive, not make an effort, pull away, the anxious attachment style often goes, that doesn't feel good or that's not healthy. And yet their subconscious is like, and we love them.
这就是你的潜意识心智所熟悉的、安全的区域。所以，当我们开始向人们投资或者我们正在约会时，你猜驱动吸引力的最大因素之一是什么？如果某人代表了潜意识的舒适区以及我们对待自己的关系模式，这意味着通常焦虑型依附的人，即使他们可能会看到某人表现冷漠、不付出努力、退缩，焦虑型依附风格往往也会觉得：这感觉不好，这不健康。然而他们的潜意识却在说：我们爱他们。
We really are so interested. We, they, you know, they're on our mind 24-7. And so it's because that subconscious comfort zone is a big factor that drives attraction. So that's really why this ends up happening. And obviously both the fearful avoidant attachment style and dismissible avoidant, they both tend to sort of push people away and kind of be a little bit dismissive or avoidant, which really feels familiar and like we have the butterflies that go off, which may actually be more like red flags that are being waved.
我们真的很感兴趣。我们，他们，你知道的，他们24小时都在我们的脑海里。所以这是因为潜意识舒适区是驱动吸引力的一个重要因素。这真的是为什么最终会发生这种情况的原因。显然，恐惧型回避依附风格和疏离型回避依附风格，它们都倾向于把人推开，表现得有点冷漠或回避，这确实让人感到熟悉，并且让我们心里小鹿乱撞，但这可能更像是正在挥舞的危险信号。
But the subconscious mind doesn't know any better. Well, it's that age-old sense, and I say this all the time, sometimes our brains, our bodies, confuse anxiety with excitement and with the spark and with passion, when that is sometimes not true. And just your brain trying to interpret a situation is more positive and is more beneficial. So this is really fascinating to me because obviously what a dismissive avoidant,
但潜意识并不知道这些。嗯，这是一种古老的感觉，我经常这样说，有时我们的大脑、我们的身体会把焦虑误认为兴奋、火花和激情，而这有时并非事实。这只是你大脑试图将某种情况解释为更加积极、更加有益。所以这对我来说非常着迷，因为很明显，疏离型回避者、
fearful avoidant and an anxiously attached person wants out of a relationship is different because what they're looking for in a relationship is different, what they want from the relationship is different. Why is that so destructive for the anxiously attached in particular? Yeah, because exactly what they do. have as their subconscious comfort zone in relationship to self, which is causing them so much pain is exactly what they end up attracting in relationships or being attracted to another. So one of the biggest things is that as anxious preoccupies, if anybody who is AP could sort of take a look,
恐惧型回避者和焦虑型依附者从关系中想要的东西是不同的，因为他们在关系中寻找的东西不同，他们对关系的需求也不同。为什么这对焦虑型依附者来说尤其具有破坏性呢？是的，因为他们自己在与自己的关系中所拥有的潜意识舒适区，正是让他们承受如此多痛苦的原因，也正是他们最终在关系中吸引或被吸引的东西。所以最大的事情之一是，作为焦虑型执念者，如果任何AP（焦虑预置型）的人可以看一看，
they would see that as an anxious preoccupied person, anxious preoccupied person, the things that they do to themselves that hurt themselves the most is that they don't speak up for their needs. They put themselves on the back burner. They, you know, pretend like things are okay with them when they're not. You know, I think of like somebody's sitting there and somebody's hurting them and they're like, it's fine. It's not a big deal because they're always prioritizing other people and getting that approval and that connection. But it's always at the expense of self-abandonment, right? So part of what happens is how we keep our subconscious wounds alive from childhood, because we have to ask ourselves the question. Like, if our wounds happened, let's say somebody's in their 20s listening to
他们会发现，作为一个焦虑预置型的人，他们对自己做的事情中伤害自己最深的，就是他们不为自己的需求大声疾呼。他们把自己的需求搁置一旁。他们，你知道的，当事情不对劲时，却假装一切都好。我想象有人坐在那里，别人在伤害他们，而他们却说：没关系，这不是什么大不了的事，因为他们总是优先考虑别人，去获得那种认可和连接。但这总是以自我抛弃为代价的，对吧？所以发生的一部分情况是，我们是如何让童年的潜意识创伤保持活力的，因为我们必须问自己这个问题。就像，如果我们的创伤发生了，比方说听你播客的人正处于20多岁。而这发生在他们身上，他们的遗弃创伤从五岁开始。它们怎么还在？
this on your podcast. And this happened, their abandonment wounds started when they were five. how are they still here? The past is, you know, 15 years gone, 20 years gone. Well, what's actually happening is that we actually can't keep wounds alive unless we're constantly opening the wound and, you know, sort of peeling off the scab on a regular basis. So the wounds stay alive for an anxious preoccupied person because they keep abandoning themselves first. And so as long as that cycle of self-abandonment, putting themselves last, not sharing their boundaries, not speaking up for their needs as long as they keep that alive in the relationship to themselves, that's still going to be what they're attracted to and others. And then when somebody else does that back to them, it hurts
过去已经过去15年了，20年了。好吧，实际发生的情况是，如果我们不不断地扯开伤口，不经常剥落结痂，我们实际上是无法让创伤保持活力的。所以焦虑预置型的创伤之所以能保持活力，是因为他们总是首先抛弃自己。因此，只要这种自我抛弃、把自己放在最后、不分享边界、不为自己的需求发声的循环在他们与自己的关系中继续保持活力，那依然会是他们所吸引的和被其他人吸引的东西。然后，当别人也这样对待他们时，就会痛上一百倍，因为那里有一个没有机会得到治愈的伤口。所以对于一个有安全感的人来说，经历这一切，他们没有这些先前存在的创伤，也就没那么大不了。而一个有这些先前存在的伤口的焦虑者，当别人触碰它时，就会痛得多。这就是需要在根本层面上真正解决这个问题的部分原因。
a hundred times more because there's a wound there that hasn't had the chance to heal. So for somebody secure to experience that, they don't have these preexisting wounds, it's not as big of a deal. Somebody anxious who has these preexisting wounds, when somebody touches it, it hurts so much more. And that's part of where that problem needs to really be solved for at root level. It also sounds like such a cycle, right? Where it's like, if the only love that you've ever come to expect and accept is this kind of blueprint, obviously you're not going to know any different. You have no idea of what love, healthy love, secure love actually feels like. So you're going to just repeat behaviors that put you in the same situation again and
这也听起来像是一个循环，对吧？就像，如果你曾经期望和接受的唯一的爱就是这种蓝图，显然你不会知道任何其他可能。你根本不知道爱、健康的爱、有安全感的爱实际上是什么感觉。所以你只会重复那些让你一次又一次陷入同样处境的行为。那么我们究竟该如何超越我们焦虑型依附的倾向呢？就像我来找你时真正想问的一个问题是：我们的依附风格是永远不变的吗？它是可以预测的吗？还是说我们可以做些什么来改变它？是的，这是一个极好的问题，而且非常重要。所以我总是对人们说的是：首先，你生来就没有什么依附风格。它是被后天塑造到你身上的。它是通过重复和情感，也就是我们一直在谈论的那个关键东西形成的。我们可以通过“重复加情感”来重新塑造它。所以有几件事我们可以做，
again and again. So how can we actually move past our anxiously attached tendencies? Like a question that I really had for you coming into this was, is our attachment style forever? Is it predictive? Or are there things that we can do about it? Yeah, it's an amazing question and such an important one. So the answer I always give to people is like, first of all, you're not born with an attachment style. It gets conditioned into you. And it's really through repetition and emotion, that sort of key thing we keep talking about. And we can recondition it through repetition plus emotion. So there's a few things that we can do. and as anxious attachment styles, there's a few core things that are really good starting places.
作为焦虑型依附风格，有一些核心事情是非常好的起点。第一，你必须了解自己的需求，你必须开始为它们大声疾呼。因为如果你试图在需求得不到满足时去为它们发声，你发声的方式往往也最不容易被听到。如果你为需求发声时说的是：你从不给我确定感。你从不花足够的时间陪我。人们听到的只是批评，这就很悲剧，因为这样一来，某人的需求得到的满足就会更少，从而陷入这种恶性循环。
One is you have to learn what your needs are and you have to start advocating for them. Because if you try to advocate for your needs when they don't get met, you advocate for them in a way where you're also less likely to be heard. So if you advocate for your needs, you're like, you never give me certainty. You never spend enough time with me. People just hear criticism and then it's tragic because then somebody gets even less needs met and it becomes this vicious cycle.
所以首要的事情之一，也是焦虑型依附在他们的关系中最需要的东西，是确定性、一致性，透明度非常重要，一种安全感、安心感、确认感、当下感，再次强调，不是礼物，而是实际的共情，某人能够将他们的存在感给予他们所爱之人的能力。以及来自伴侣的很多鼓励。这八件事往往是焦虑型依附风格在一段关系中能够真正感到安全所必需的顶级需求。休息，减压。但作为焦虑型依附风格，我们也必须，作为自我安抚的一部分，
So one of the first things and what anxious attachments tend to need the most in their relationships is certainty, consistency, transparency is very important, a sense of safety, reassurance, validation, presence, again, not gifts, but like actual like attunements, somebody giving their ability to be present to the person they love. And a lot of encouragement from their partners. Like those eight things tend to be really top tier needs for anxious attachment styles to feel like they can really feel safe in a relationship. rest, decompress. But we also have to, as anxious attachment style, is part of self-soothing
并且当你在作为焦虑型依附风格感受到那种恐慌时，当你心想“哦天哪”，那种恐慌在你的身体里活跃，你正在经历那种创伤反应时，你学习如何自我安抚的一部分，好让你不必总是再次打电话或做类似的事情，就是通过重复和情感，在与自己的关系中学会给予这些需求。因此，如果一个焦虑型依附风格了解了自己的需求，知道这八大顶级需求是什么，开始在日常生活中重复地将这些给予自己，比如每天肯定自己的微小胜利，通过问正确的问题来创造确定感，但同时也把这些需求带入他们与其他人的关系中并让别人知道，
and not feeling when you feel that sense of panic as an anxious attachment style where you're like, oh my gosh, and that panic's alive in your body and you're having that kind of trauma response. Part of how you learn to self-sooth so that it doesn't always have to be calling again or things like that is to learn to give those needs in the relationship to yourself through repetition and emotion. So if an anxious attachment style learns their needs, knows that those are their top eight needs, starts giving those to themselves repetitively on a daily basis, like validating their wins each day, creating a sense of certainty by asking the right questions, but then also brings those needs into their relationships with others and let them be known,
为它们发声，练习那种脆弱。这是焦虑型依附者开始疗愈的第一个巨大起点。第二个对焦虑型依附风格深有影响的起点是，有时AP（焦虑预置型）往往会陷入一种纠缠和共生状态。这意味着当他们进入一段关系时，他们会把那个人当成他们宇宙的中心。这并不是说某人不能成为你生命中这个巨大的、美丽的、了不起的人，因为他们绝对可以，而且也应该如此。但焦虑型依附风格有时会开始侵蚀生活中其他领域的精力。例如，当他们处于一段浪漫关系中时，他们会花更少的时间关注朋友、家人、他们的职业、财务、身体健康、
asks for them, practices that vulnerability. That's a first huge place for anxious attachments to start healing. And a second place that's really profound for anxious attachment styles is sometimes APs tend to get into a space where they'll go into enmeshment and codependency. meaning when they get into a relationship, they will make that person the center of their universe. And it doesn't mean that somebody can't be like this massive, huge, beautiful, amazing person in your life because they absolutely can and they should be. But anxious attachment cells sometimes will start chipping away at the other areas of life. So for example, when they're in a romantic relationship, they'll spend less time focusing on friends, family, their career, their finances, their physical health,
他们的身心健康。你看，生活中有那么多领域都是极其宝贵的。但有时焦虑预置型在进入一段关系时，会把这些搁置一旁。你越多地放弃自己，你越是不再以一种平衡的方式跨越生活的那些不同领域进行关注，比如你把职业目标搁置一回合，只优先考虑你的关系，你把所有的预算都花出去买新衣服来给约会对象留下深刻印象，或者把钱花在高档晚宴上，
their mental, emotional health. Like, there's so many areas of life that are really valuable. But sometimes anxious preoccupies will kind of, like, put them on the back burner when they get into a relationship. The more that you give yourself away, the more that you stop focusing in a sort of balanced way across those different areas of life, like you put your career goals on hold, you're just prioritizing your relationship, you spend all your budget going out to, you know, buy new clothes and impress the person you're dating or spend money on a fancy dinners.
你知道的，你越多地放弃自己，却不去考虑这些选择如何在核心层面上影响你，也不把自己看作是一个与对方平等的人，你就会在潜意识里给这段关系施加更多压力，因为那个人成了你的整个世界，而你却在忽视你世界的其他部分。所以焦虑型依附风格疗愈的另一个非常重要的部分，是确保你为生活中那些能充实你的其他领域腾出空间和时间。这实际上会帮助你保持真正的脚踏实地、居中和专注。然后我要说的第三件非常有价值的事情，我称之为质疑你的故事。这是重塑思维的一种形式。
you know, the more that you give yourself up without like actually considering how those choices are affecting you at your core and not seeing yourself as also a person equal to the other person, the more you will then subconsciously put stress on the relationship because it's like that person becomes your whole world because you're ignoring the other parts of your world. So another really important part of healing for anxious attachment style is to make sure that you're making space and time for the other areas of your life that fill you up. That will actually, help you stay really grounded and centered and present. And then I would say a third thing that tends to be really valuable is I call this just questioning your stories. It's a form of reprogramming.
如果我们重复这样做，它会非常非常有价值。但作为一种焦虑型依附风格，你知道的，作为一个经历过这些的人，我曾是恐惧型回避。所以我也有焦虑的一面，听起来你也经历过，这太容易了。就像有人不回你电话，你的脑海会飘向哪里？你会想：哦天哪，他们要离开我了。他们不会回来了。他们对我的兴趣正在减退。
If we do it repetitively, it's very, very valuable. But as an anxious attachment cell, you know, as somebody who's lived through this, I was fearful avoidance. So I had the anxious side and it sounds like you've lived through this is it's so easy. Like somebody doesn't call you back and where does your mind go? It's like, oh my gosh, they're leaving me. They're not coming back. They're losing interest. you know, and we jump to conclusions based on our own preexisting core wounds. But if we can really sit in that story and we can question it, we can say, okay, they didn't call me back and it means they're leaving me right now. Is that really true? Can I 100% know
你知道的，我们根据自己先前存在的内核创伤仓促下结论。但如果我们能真正坐下来审视那个故事并质疑它，我们可以说：好吧，他们没有回我电话，这意味着他们现在要离开我。这真的是真的吗？我能100%确定那是真的吗？我们可以借此机会削弱那个故事的气焰——那个想要带我们以每小时百万英里的速度冲向所有可能发生的最坏情况的故事。当我们能在光天化日之下审视这些叙事时，有时我们会想：他们没回电话，他们遭遇了车祸，所有这些坏事都在发生。我们可以投射出所有这些可怕的场景。当我们学会见证这些想法并对其进行质疑，而不是陷得太深时，我们也能以一种强有力的方式自我安抚。如果我们重复这样做，许多这样的故事就会停止再次出现，因为重复
that that's true? And we can just take the wind out of the sails of like that, that story that wants to take us a million miles an hour down to like all the worst case scenarios that are going to happen when we can hold those narratives in the light where sometimes we go, they didn't call me back, they got in a car accident, all these bad things are happening. We can really project all these scary scenarios. When we can learn to witness those thoughts and just question them and not jump too far into them, we can also self-soothe in a powerful way. And if we do that repetitively, a lot of those stories stop showing back up because repetition
加上情感实际上是在重编程它，使其不再是我们习惯思考的舒适区。所以我可以说这是三个非常非常强大的开始切入点。我喜欢这些建议。关于最后一点，还要补充一点，就是直接去问。就像：你怎么不直接问呢？这太搞笑了，对于任何有安全感依附的人来说，他们可能会想：“嘿，你为什么不回我消息？我很恼火”，但对于其他人来说，他们会想：“怎么回事，我怎么能这么说？这不会把他们推得更远吗？”但事实是
and emotion is actually reprogramming that from being that comfort zone of what we're used to thinking. So I'd say those are three really, really powerful places to start. I love those tips. And further to the last one as well, just ask. Just be like, how you didn't just ask this. like it's so it's so funny that like it's it seems so like I think for anyone who is like securely attached they'd be like hey why didn't you reply to me like I'm annoyed but for anyone else they'd be like how what do you mean I can say that isn't that just going to drive them away further but it's
你可以直接问。而我实际上要补充的另一件事是，有时当我们，我认为当我们没有得到我们认为自己应得的爱时，当爱处于赤字状态时，我们的供应量真的很低——不是为了使用经济学术语——但当我们觉得爱处于赤字状态时，我们会把它视为生活中我们唯一想要的东西，我们把它高高举起。当然，爱是如此重要，它是作为人类的生命之源，但你唯一有价值的地方并非只有你被爱的能力。我也认为爱不仅仅必须来自其他人。你可以向自己展现你期望从其他人那里得到的爱。我总是从爱情语言的角度来思考这一点，对吧？
like no you can just ask and the other thing that I would actually add to that is sometimes when we I think when we haven't had the love that we think we deserve when love has been like in a deficit we've had a really like the supply has been low right not to use like an economics term but when we feel like love has been in a deficit we see it as like the only thing that we want in life and we are and we put it on such a pedestal and of course love is so important it is like the lifeblood of being a human that is not the only thing about you that is valuable is your capacity to be loved and I also think that love isn't something that only has to come from other people. You can show yourself the love that you expect from others. I always think about this in the sense of like the love languages, right?
我们不断地认为我们需要从别人那里获得肯定的话语、从别人那里获得服务行为、从别人那里获得身体接触，以满足这些需求，但实际上，在你感到非常焦虑、非常被抛弃、或者试图将每一件小事都灾难化的时候，你完全可以为自己践行你的爱情语言。给自己一个拥抱。对自己说肯定的话。去散步，给自己买点小零食、果汁、能让你感觉好一点的东西，以此来向自己展示那种
We constantly think that we need to receive words of affirmation from someone else, acts of service from someone else, physical touch from someone else in order to fill up those needs, but you can actually perform your love languages for yourself in those moments where you're feeling really anxious or really abandoned or really like trying to catastrophize every small thing. Like give yourself a hug. Speak words of affirmation to yourself. Go and take yourself on a walk and buy yourself like a little treat, a juice, something that's going to make you feel better as a way to show yourself the love
你不断期望从别人那里得到、并且也应该从别人那里得到的爱，但同时你也应该同等地对自己的爱有所期待。我太喜欢了。这太美妙了。有趣的是，我们经常对此谈论很多，而你恰好说到了点子上，那就是——我们实际上通过我们的爱情语言、同时也通过我们的需求给予自己爱。所以那些我们觉得非常迫切地需要别人给予的东西，当我们只是希望他们接电话、或者只是希望他们回电话、或者只是希望他们多发短信时，做一个有价值的练习往往是去给予这些爱情语言。绝对的。而对焦虑预置型来说最大的是通常
that you're constantly expecting from others and should be expecting from others, but also should equally expect from yourself. I love that. That's so beautiful. and it's so funny because we talk a lot about this too and you just nailed it which is like we we actually give love to ourselves through our love languages but also through our needs and so the things that we feel like we're needing so badly from somebody when we just want them to answer the phone or we just want them to call us back or we just want them to text us more it's often a really valuable exercise to give those love languages absolutely and the big ones for anxious preoccupies are usually
高质量的陪伴、身体接触、肯定的话语——这些通常是焦虑型依附的前几大需求，但同时也要思考：“好吧，到底是我有什么需求如此迫切地想要从他们那里得到？”当你说了那段美妙的话时，你知道，通常这代表了一种赤字，那些觉得爱是他们宇宙中心的人。我确实同意你的看法。这就像是作为人类的生命之源。如果我们非常非常渴望从别人身上得到它，这总是意味着我们在与自己的关系中没有足够的爱。
quality time physical touch words of affirmation like those are usually the top tier ones for anxious but then also to be like, well, what is it that I need from them so badly? And when you said that beautiful thing where, you know, often like it represents a deficit, people who feel like love is the center of their universe. And I do agree with you. It's like the lifeblood of being a human being. And if we're yearning for it from other people so, so much, it always means that we don't have enough in the relationship to ourselves.
因此我们可以，我们不必只在焦虑时这样做。我们可以在焦虑并需要别人的东西时，去满足自己的需求或爱情语言。但同样地，我们在日常生活中越是养成积极的习惯并去实践它。我们越是去展现并建立这些日常例行，我们就把自己的油箱加了一半油。而焦虑型依附风格身上正在发生的一部分情况是，他们没有把自己的油箱加到一半。所以当别人无法填满他们的油箱的那一刻，就像你开着汽车，你知道自己只剩下两公里油一样，对吧？就像你已经见底了，所以我们开始恐慌。
And so we can, we don't have to just do that when we're anxious. We can do that where we meet our needs or love language is when we're anxious and needing something from others. but also the more we make like active habits and practice out of it on a daily basis. And the more we just show up and create those routines in our lives, we fill our bucket halfway. And part of what's happening for anxious attachment styles is that they're not filling their bucket halfway. So the moment somebody else can't fill their bucket, it's like driving around with your gas tank and you know that you have like two kilometers left, right? It's like you're right down to the brim and so we panic.
因此我们不仅在焦虑时可以这样做。我们在焦虑且需要他人给予时，可以通过满足需求或爱的语言来做到这一点，而且我们越是将其作为日常的积极习惯和练习，越是频繁地出现并在生活中建立这些常规，我们就越能把自己的水桶填满一半。焦虑型依恋的人身上发生的一部分情况是，他们没有把自己的水桶填满一半。所以当另一个人无法填满他们的水桶时，那种感觉就像是开着油箱所剩无几的车，你知道大概只剩两公里了，对吧？就像是已经见底了，所以我们会恐慌。
But if you can get into the habit to always driving with a half tank full, then if somebody can't, go from, you know, pull in your gas tank and go from half to full, you're still totally fine and it's completely okay. And so, you know, if you're seeing that in your life, being able to give yourself to that proactively and habitually make such a difference and also really helps retrain the subconscious mind to get more secure in the relationship to self. I love that analogy. I absolutely adore that analogy. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental
但如果你养成总是保持半箱油的习惯，那么如果有人没法从——你知道的，把油箱加满再从半箱开到满——你其实也完全没问题，这完全可以接受。所以，你知道的，如果你在生活中看到了这一点，能够主动且习惯性地对自己做出这种改变，就会产生巨大的差异，并且真的有助于重塑潜意识，让我们在自我关系中获得更多安全感。我太喜欢这个比喻了。我简直爱死这个比喻了。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理坚韧度、体能以及建立韧性的科学。
toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
坚韧、健身，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开交流，看穿那些统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 TWO%。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得 Diana Ross 在 VMA 上拍打 Little Kim 的胸部吗？或者当 Kanye 说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell to George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟 Little Kim到底有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是 Sam J。还有我 Alex English。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个热点，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一期节目，我们请来了 Lamont Hill，畅谈80年代的瘾品。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为瘾品。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我其实随时都可以聊聊瘾品，不过只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们第二期讨论瘾品了。所以我开始发现这里面有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你把这句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
对我而言，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师 Kear Games。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的有。Trip Fontaine，Ryan Clark。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person
我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。Steve Burns，Dustin Ross。因为你觉得做一个好人很重要
while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
当你活在世上的时候。你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我的新播客《迎难而上》，与我 Kear Gaines 一起，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真实的对话，
Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones.
《Learn the Hard Way》。打开你免费的 iHeart Radio 应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律之战，只为证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋，以及迈克尔·纳拉尼尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Thank you so much for coming on the show and for spreading your wisdom. I feel like I actually learned so much.
这是《陷入爱河的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。非常感谢你来到节目中并分享你的智慧。我觉得我真的学到了很多。
Like I'm listening to, I was listening to you being like, that is just making so much sense for me. Everything is checking out. I can apply so much of this to my relationship and my past relationships and the relationships that I've had with my parents and so many other people in my life. So I want to thank you again for finding the time. to come on the podcast and share your wisdom. Where can the listeners find you? Thank you so much. Thank you for sharing all that too. So you can find me at Personal Development School dash Taise Gibson. It's spelled T-H-A-I-S, kind of like Thai with an S at the
就像我在听，我刚才听你说话时觉得，这对我来说太有道理了。一切都说得通。我可以把这里的很多内容应用到我的恋爱关系、过去的恋爱关系，以及我与父母和生活中许多其他人建立的关系中。所以我再次感谢你抽出时间来到播客并分享你的智慧。听众在哪里可以找到你？非常感谢。也谢谢你分享了这一切。你可以在 Personal Development School 找到我，连字符，泰丝·吉布森（Taise Gibson）。拼写是 T-H-A-I-S，有点像泰式（Thai）后面加了个 S，
end, but just personal development school will show up. And then also, if anybody wants a free attachment style quiz, we have a free quiz that tells you like your attachment style and then it gives you a report on like your wounds, your needs, the ways you can communicate, It gives like some supportive tools all for free at www. www.personaldevelopment school.com. Oh my goodness. I'm going to go and do that now. I feel like I know the answer, but what a good resource.
结尾，但直接搜个人发展学校（personal development school）就能找到。另外，如果有人想要免费的依恋风格测试，我们有一个免费测试，可以告诉你你的依恋风格，然后会给你一份关于你的创伤、你的需求、你的沟通方式的报告，它还提供了一些支持性的工具，全部都是免费的，网址是 www.personaldevelopment school.com。哦，天哪。我现在就要去做。我觉得我大概知道答案，但这个资源真是太棒了。
Also, there are so many attachment quizzes out there that it's like, we can tell you your attachment style in like five questions. And then you have to pay, you have to like submit, like you've got to pay for it. It's like $50 and it like doesn't tell you anything. Yeah, yeah. Ours is free. And I think there's about 30 questions on there to really get into like the nitty
此外，市面上有那么多的依恋风格测试，它们会说“我们通过五个问题就能告诉你你的依恋风格”。然后你必须付费，你必须提交资料，还得花钱。大概要50美元，结果却什么也测不出来。对，对。我们的测试是免费的。而且我认为上面大约有30个问题，能真正深入到核心细节，
gritty and really get you a clear answer. I'm so excited. I'm actually going to go and do it. I'm going to send it to my friends as well. So again, thank you so much for coming on the show. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. If there is a friend who needs to hear this, maybe you should share them a link. Send it along. Share the love. Maybe they'll learn something.
并为你提供一个清晰的答案。我太兴奋了。我实际上就要去做一下。我也会把它发给我的朋友们。所以再次感谢你来到节目。像往常一样，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果有朋友需要听听这个，也许你应该把链接发给他。转发一下。传递爱心。也许他们能学到点什么。
And make sure that you are following us so you know when new episodes come out. And finally, if you have an episode suggestion, if you want us to talk more about maybe the dismissive avoidant, the fearful avoidant, please reach out to me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram and have a lovely week. We would be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have. have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the
请确保关注我们，这样你就不会错过新发布的剧集。最后，如果你对节目有什么建议，或者希望我们多聊聊比如疏离回避型、恐惧回避型，请在 Instagram 上通过 That Psychology Podcast 联系我，祝大家度过美好的一周。我们下周将带来另一期节目。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《迎难而上》，我是你们最喜欢治疗师兼主持人 Kear Gaines。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在别处根本无法安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一身铠甲。这向全世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力，就一定要去，请收听
hard way on the I-Hard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen. Correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini.
在 i-Heart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理坚韧度、体能以及建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 TWO%。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们常说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们》。
Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts、以及你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。